Now that you know a little more
about enumerations, structs, and
classes in Swift, I want to play a game
I'm calling enum, class, or struct?
Choose the right type for the job.
So for each type I describe,
we're going to choose whether we should
use an enum, a class, or a struct.
The first one is a triangle.
It has two properties, an array
of angles and an array of sides.
And I think we should choose, struct.
This is a simple type, just a couple
collections with few values each.
And one might imagine that each time
we make a triangle we want a distinct
copy to be made.
Also, there's no need for inheritance.
If we did want inheritance, for
example for an isosceles triangle and
a right triangle
the subclass from triangle.
In that case we'd choose class.
Number two,
UIImagePickerControllerSourceType.
This is the type that indicates
where images should be chosen from,
when they're being attached to
a text message, for example.
Our biggest clue here is that the source
type has three distinct values,
photo library, camera and
saved photos album.
So we should choose, enum.
The UIImagePickerControllerSourceType
is indeed an enumeration.
Enums are convenient for
types that can be described as one
property with a finite number of values.
Here's another one.
We need a type for a name object which
holds two strings, a first name and
a last name.
Again, I would choose struct
because we're dealing with few
relatively simple values.
And we're probably going to want every
instance of a name to have its own copy.
Let's go through just a couple more.
let's say we need a type to represent
a subject in secondary school.
This is a very traditional school at
which there are only four subjects.
Math, English, Spanish and Science.
What would you choose?
For this one again with a finite
number of values an enumeration
would work well.
This last one is a little more complex.
Here we need a type to
represent a student.
It will have a grades property to hold
an array of grades, a name property to
hold a name, a favorite subject
property which holds a subject, and
a computed property to hold
the grade point average.
Additionally there are a few
different types of students.
High school, elementary school,
and middle school.
So we want those subtypes to be able to
inherit from the more generally defined
student type.
So what kind of type should we choose?
For this one, we'll want a class.
Between classes, enums, and structs,
only classes have inheritance.
On top of that, the structure of this
type is a little more complex than
you see in most structs.
A struct could hold the data,
but it would be unusual.
That ought to give you a good
start on structs and enumerations.
Be sure of complete the exercises to
deepen your understanding of value types
and reference types, and for more
practice choosing the right type for
your needs.
Stay tuned to learn about how to expand
and customize the functionality of
all of these type's with protocols and
extensions.